>> Greg: IT'S AN ALL GIRLS
SCHOOL EXCEPT FOR THE ALL GIRLS
RULE, AND NOW THEY'RE AWARD A
CAP AND GOWN IF YOU ONLY USE THE
RIGHT PRONOUN.
HARPES HALL, AN ELITE SCHOOL IN
NASHVILLE, CHANGED ITS ADMISSION
POLICIES TO ACCEPT BIOLOGICAL
MALES WHO SIMPLY SAY THEY'RE
GIRLS.
THE SAME POLICY I USE TO GET
FREE MY TIES ON LADY'S NIGHTS.
IT DATES BACK TO THE 1800s WHEN
BIOLOGY WAS FAR LEFT ADVANCED
AND RELIED ON PHYSIOLOGY INSTEAD
OF TRENDS ON TWITTER.
TO BE HONEST THERE WERE SOME
GENDER PEOPLE BACK THEN AS NOTED
IN THE NOVEL MEN WHO IDENTIFY AS
LITTLE WOMEN.
THAT'S PRETTY FUNNY.
THEY ACTUALLY MADE THE COVER.
THEY DON'T DO THAT ON SPECIAL
REPORT.
THEY ANNOUNCED THE CHANGE IN A
NEW GENDER DIVERSITY FLOSSITY
E-MAIL TO PARENTS, QUOTE, ANY
STUDENT WHO IDENTIFIES AS A GIRL
MAY APPLY TO MY SCHOOL.
STUDENTS WHO JOIN AND REMAIN
HERE DO SO BECAUSE OUR MISSION
AS A SCHOOL RESONATES WITH THEM.
THE TRUTH IS, WHAT YOU FEEL,
EVEN IF YOU FEEL BALD.
TRANSLATION, BIOLOGICAL MALES
ARE NOW ALLOWED AS LONG AS YOU
COMMIT TO YOUR PRONOUNS, THE
LETTER CONTINUES IF A STUDENT
COMMUNICATES A DESIRE TO BE
IDENTIFIED AS MALE OR ADOPT
HE/HIM PRONOUNS WE RECOGNIZE
THAT AT OUR SCHOOL.
BEING A GIRLS SCHOOL MAY NO
LONGER BE A PLACE THAT SERVES
THAT STUDENT WELL.
WELL, THEY'RE CONSISTENT,
NOTHING MAKES SENSE.
BY THE WAY, HARPETH HALL COUNTS
REESE WITHERSPOON AND AMY GRANT
AS ALUMNI TWO PEOPLE WE KNOW ARE
WOMEN AFTER BRIEF ROMANCES.
IT MAKES ME WONDER WHAT'S THE
POINTS OF A GIRLS SCHOOL AT ALL?
YOU KNOW, ASIDE FROM THE PILLOW
FIGHTS.
>> A SEXIST WOULD SAY.
>> Greg: DAGEN, GOOD OR BAD
IDEA?
>> Dagen: I WOULD SAY TO ANY
TRANS GIRL WHO MIGHT WANT TO GO
THERE, DON'T, HANG OUT WITH THE
BOYS.
BECAUSE I DID GO TO AN ALL GIRLS
SOUTHERN SCHOOL FOR A FEW YEARS,
AND YOU DON'T WANT TO HANG OUT
WITH THOSE BITCHES.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dagen: YOU ENCOUNTER A LOT OF
MAGNOLIA MOUTH, WHICH IS
SOMEBODY WHO'S DRIPPINGLY SWEET
TO YOUR FACE AND THEN TALKS
HEAPS OF [BLEEP] BEHIND YOUR
BACK.
>> Bret: BLESS YOUR HEART.
>> Dagen: RIGHT.
BUT NOT EVEN THAT.
YOU'RE SO FUNNY LOVE HANGING OUT
WITH YOU AND THEN THEY CALL YOU
LIKE DONUT DORIS BEHIND YOUR
BACK BECAUSE YOU SMELL LIKE
KRISPY KREME KRISPY KREME.
SO DON'T GO THERE.
BY THE WAY, IT'S A PLOY TO GET
WOMEN IN OR GIRLS IN, BECAUSE
THE ENROLLMENT AT ALL THESE
SCHOOLS ARE GOING, BECAUSE
THEY'RE HORRIBLE PLACES.
>> Greg: THINKING, BRET, THAT I
SHOULD APPLY AND IDENTIFY AS A
YOUNG GIRL.
BECAUSE IF YOU CAN CHANGE YOUR
GENDER WITHOUT A BIOLOGICAL
UNDERPINNING WHY CAN'T YOU DO
THE SAME WITH AGE RIGHT?
I KNOW YOU'RE IN, WHAT, YOUR
EARLY 60s, BUT YOU COULD
PROBABLY JUST DECIDE, I'M 35.
SO WHY CAN'T I BE LIKE -- WHAT'S
THE COOL AGE FOR THESE GIRLS?
I DIDN'T READ THAT PART.
>> Tyrus: COLLEGE.
>> Greg: COLLEGE?
OH, I'M AN A 18 YEAR OLD
INCOMING BLOND FEMALE.
WHY CAN'T I DO THAT?
>> Bret: SURE, WHY NOT.
>> WHY CAN'T WE DO IT TOGETHER.
>> Bret: NO.
>> Greg: WHY DON'T WE JUST LEAVE
THIS PLACE BRET?
WHAT ARE WE DOING FOR OUR LIVES.
>> Bret: I DON'T KNOW.
IS THIS WHERE I LEAVE?
>> Greg: NO.
>> Bret: OKAY.
>> Greg: WE LEAVE TOGETHER.
>> Bret: I IDENTIFY AS SIN, BUT
I'M REALLY NOT.
THIS IS WHERE YOU LOSE A LOT OF
THE COUNTRY.
YOU LOSE A LOT OF MIDDLE
AMERICA.
YOU LOSE HISPANIC COMMUNITIES.
YOU LOSE, YOU KNOW, SOUTHERN
BAPTIST AFRICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITIES, THIS IS WHERE THE
DISCONNECT REALLY HAPPENS
POLITICALLY AT LEAST WHERE THEY
SAY WHAT?
WHAT IS THIS.
>> Greg: YEAH.
TYRUS, IF YOU REMOVE THE
BIOLOGICAL REALITY FROM LIFE, I
SHOULD BE ABLE TO ENTER THE
WESTMINSTER DOG SHOW.
BEAT THOSE BITCHES.
>> Tyrus: OH, I WOULD LOVE TO
WALK YOU.
>> Greg: I WOULD LOVE TO CRAWL
THROUGH THOSE LITTLE TUNNELS.
>> Tyrus: YOU WOULD.
PROBABLY WIN.
>> Greg: I WOULD.
I THINK I WOULD WIN.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH YOU?
>> Tyrus: I DON'T KNOW.
I'M JUST SO SHOCKED AT THE
SEXIST IN THE STORY.
>> Greg: WHAT'S WRONG --.
>> Tyrus: SO BOYS STILL CAN'T
GET IN?
THAT'S JUST NOT FAIR.
MAKE IT EVERYBODY'S SCHOOL.
THIS IS, AGAIN, THIS ALWAYS --
THEY SAY THINGS THAT DON'T
TRANSLATE WELL.
AND WHAT DO YOU DO THE FIRST
TIME AN ASSAULT HAPPENS, WHAT DO
YOU THE FIRST TIME THESE THINGS
HAPPEN.
WHAT DO YOU WITH THE GIRL OR
FAMILY IS UNCOMFORTABLE SHARING
BATHROOMS AND SHOWERS IN YOU
WANT TO CELEBRATE THE INDIVIDUAL
BUT THAT'S EVERYONE.
IT HAS TO BE SOMETHING, ARE THE
FACILITIES PREPARED FOR THIS?
YOU KNOW, BECAUSE, AT THE END OF
THE DAY, A BOY WHO DECIDES TO
IDENTIFY AS A GIRL OR WHATEVER
AND 95% OF THE TIME YOU HOPE
IT'S A NICE HEALTHY SITUATION
AND SOMETIMES IT'S NOT.
WE'VE SEEN IT IN OTHER SCHOOLS
AND SITUATIONS BUT AGAIN THEY
DON'T TRY TO FIX PROBLEMS.
THEY SAY THAT.
WE'RE JUST GOING TO OPEN IT UP
IF YOU IDENTIFY WE'RE IN AND
WE'RE VIRTUE SIGNALING AND WE'RE
GREAT.
I DID NOTICE IT SAYS APPLY.
YOU CAN APPLY.
EVERY JOB THAT I'VE EVER ASKED
ABOUT WHERE THEY SAY, WELL,
TYRUS, YOU'RE WELCOME TO APPLY.
WE'RE NOT HIRING YOUR BIG ASS
ANYTIME SOON, BUT WE'LL KEEP
YOUR APP ON FILE TO REMIND US
NOT TO HIRE YOUR BIG ASS ANYTIME
SOON.
>> Greg: THAT IS SO TRUE.
ANYTIME I'VE BEEN ASKED.
>> Tyrus: YOU CAN APPLY.
>> Greg: YOU CAN APPLY, NOTHING
EVER HAPPENS.
>> Tyrus: NO.
>> Kat: THAT'S ALMOST THE MOST
INTERESTING PART OF THIS.
>> Greg: WHAT?
>> Kat: WHICH IS THIS SENTENCE
IN CASES OF NON-BINARY STUDENTS
OR HOSE THOUGH USE THEY/THEM
PRONOUNS WILL BE ADDRESSED ON AN
INDIVIDUAL BASIS.
WHAT IS THAT BASIS.
>> Bret: RIGHT, THEY'RE THEY
>> Kat: HOW DOES THAT
CONVERSATION GO?
SOME THEYS GET IN AND NOT
OTHERS, BUT WHAT IF YOU'RE A
GIRL AND YOU BECOME A THEY ARE
YOU GRAND FATHERED IN OR DO YOU
HAVE TO HAVE A MEETING.
>> Greg: INTERESTING IF YOU'RE
GRAND FATHERED IN.
>> Kat: LIKE YOU'RE A GIRL BUT
NOW I'M THEY.
DO THEY BRING YOU TO THE OFFICE
LIKE EXCUSE ME WE HEARD YOU'RE A
THEY NOW AND WE NEED TO TALK
ABOUT IF YOU CAN STILL GO TO
SCHOOL HERE.
>> Tyrus: DO THEY SET TRAPS
>> Kat: IS THERE A COMMITTEE?
I DON'T UNDERSTAND.
>> Tyrus: HID BEHIND A LOCKER.
GOT HIM
>> Kat: IF YOU WANT TO PAY
$33,000 A YEAR AND THIS IS WHA